et le hard rock vous aimez ça la torah
début des années 80 le hard rock
débarque en france
mais tout le monde ne connaît pas la
drague des groupes comme ac/dc scorpions
metallica moto raid se produit sur les
scènes françaises
au même moment un seul groupe français
est vraiment connu trust cette logique
on l'a fait depuis le début du gauche se
dire qu'on n'a pas attendu que le
pouvoir revienne au hard rock pour
refaire du hard rock dans les médias
quelques reportages sur ce nouveau genre
musical mais surtout beaucoup de
questions
qu'est ce qui peut bien pousser ces
jeunes gens tous plus gentils les uns
que les autres
avoir besoin d'une telle dépense
d'énergie des piles si forte expansion
google chaque sujet c'est le même
refrain et les mêmes a priori ce genre
musical fait peur il est violent exemple
avec le chanteur de motörhead qui jouent
le jeu du journaliste ouais je vais à ce
match si les clichés amusé les chanteurs
pour les adeptes se catalogage devient
un brin pénible moyen de papillons et
j'écoute du hard rock cha fanatiques de
la banque
alors on a une image un peu négatif par
rapport à ça très rarement médiatisé le
hard rock nourrit les fantasmes les fans
dénoncé d'ailleurs le peu de temps
d'antenne consacré à ce genre musical
que le choix des médias vis-à-vis de
certains groupes de certains mouvements
parce que du smart on en voit souvent
puis quand on nous les leur dos on ne
voit jamais de hard à la télé encore
aujourd'hui le hard rock est quasi
absent des chaînes musicales
pourtant ses fans sont toujours aussi
nombreux de quoi répondre à ce p'tit
métallo des années 80 oui on peut être
vieux et aimer métal et musicaux
qu'on aime quand les jeunes et puis
après bomba des fois c'est sûr il y en a
qui vont ça va devenir des beaufs mais
c'est ce qu'il faut lutter pour pas
devenir sa môman voilà
[Musique]